the results of our presidential election  were shocking not only here in America  but they were shocking all around the  world in England today this is true the  Daily Mirror had this headline this is  the headline at the debonair that's bets  yes that is real turns out a lot of  foreign newspapers had their own take on  Donald Trump's victory france's  newspaper had this headline right here  what left  [Applause]  turns out we all know Franchot italy had  this headline oh my god are they elected  a meatball  yeah the Irish Times had this headline  from sake America these Slovenian times  at this headline look our former hot  booby girl is queen of America the the  Vatican Vatican newspaper had lent very  surprising check it out is from the  Vatican look what it says it says there  is no God it's pretty rough for them a  newspaper in Germany had this headline  at least we've never done that and  finally there's the paper in Moscow that  said just simply we did it  you  you